WORLD."
I'M BECKY ANDERSON.
LET'S GET STRAIGHT TO OUR TOP
STORY FOR YOU.
HOPE FOR SURVIVORS AFTER ONE OF
THE MOST HEINOUS ATTACK IN
RUSSIA'S THREE-WEEK LONG
INVASION OF UKRAINE.
OFFICIALS IN UKRAINE SAYING
PEOPLE WERE SEEN WALKING OUT OF
A BOMBED OUT THEATER SEVERAL
HOURS AGO IN THE BESIEGED CITY
OF MARIUPOL.
THE SAME BUILDING THAT HUNDREDS
OF TRAUMATIZED FAMILIES HAD BEEN
USING TO TAKE COVER FROM RUSSIAN
ATTACKS.
UKRAINE'S DEFENSE MINISTER WITH
SEARING CRITICISM DIRECTED
TOWARDS WHOEVER ORDERED THAT
BOMBING.
>> YOU CAN SEE FROM THE MAPS,
FROM THE DRONES AROUND THIS,
THERE IS A BIG LETTER OF
CHILDREN, WRITTEN SO THAT THE
PILOT OF THE PLANE WHICH WAS
THROWING THE BOMBS COULD SEE,
AND STILL IN SPITE OF THAT, THIS
MONSTER HAS BOMBED THE THEATER.
>> WELL, NICK PATON WALSH IS
REPORTING TODAY FROM ODESA.
HE TELLS US THE MARE RIUPOL THER
AT
ATTACK IS PART OF THE WAR.
>> Reporter: ENCOURAGING NEWS
EMERGING FROM MARIUPOL OF PEOPLE
COMING OUT OF THAT BOMB SHELTER,
UNKNOWN THE NUMBERS THAT WERE IN
THERE OR THE NUMBERS THAT APPEAR
TO HAVE SURVIVED AT THIS STAGE.
IT IS STILL A PATCHY PIECE OF
INFORMATION AT THIS POINT.
BUT CERTAINLY THAT DOESN'T
DETRACT FROM THE CLEAR DECISION
MADE BY RUSSIAN FORCES TO LAUNCH
AN AIR STRIKE AGAINST A BUILDING
THAT HAD CHILDREN WRITTEN LARGE
ON BOTH SIDES OF IT OUTSIDE.
HERE IS SOME OF THE SCENES THAT
EMERGED LAST NIGHT.
THE FLICKER OF FLAME HERE, WHERE
RUSSIA'S BARBARISM PEAKED, AND
HUNDREDS BENEATH A THEATER, SAID
LOCAL OFFICIALS.
THE DAMAGE SO COMPLETE, THE
ENTRANCE WAS REDUCED TO RUBBLE.
THIS SATELLITE IMAGE FROM TWO
DAYS EARLIER SHOWING THE
BUILDING STANDING WITH CHILDREN
WRITTEN LARGE OUTSIDE.
IN CASE YOU'RE STILL THINKING
NOBODY KNEW WHO WAS HERE, VIDEOS
HAD BEEN CIRCULATING FOR DAYS OF
THE HELL INSIDE.
HOW OVER A WEEK OF SIEGE AND
SHELLING HAD FORCED THOSE STILL
LIVING INTO A SPACE SO TIGHT AND
DARK IT MUST HAVE FELT LIKE A
TOMB
TOMB.
HERE, HE SAYS, THIS IS WHERE WE
GIVE OUT CHILDREN.
CHILDREN, WOMEN AND ELDERLY
FIRST.
THIS IS THE CONVERTED CLOAK ROOM
OF THE THEATER.
IF THIS LOOKS LIKE HOW YOU
IMAGINE THE END OF THE WORLD,
FOR THESE CHILDREN, PACKED IN,
THAT MAY HAVE BEEN THE CASE WHEN
THE BOMBS STRUCK.
RUSSIA CLAIMED UKRAINIAN
RADICALS CAUSED THE BLAST.
IN THIS ROOM, 15 PEOPLE.
LITTLE COMFORT ANY PARENT CAN
GIVE.
ABLY BELOW THIS DOOR, THERE ARE
MORE, AN ENTIRE CITY FORCED
UNDERGROUND, VERY LITTLE AID
ALLOWED IN AND FEW ALLOWED OUT.
PEOPLE, HEAR US, HERE ARE
CHILDREN, HE SAYS.
THIS APPEAL IS FOR FOOD, HELP,
PERHAPS UNAWARE IT MAY HAVE LED
RUSSIAN BOMBS STRAIGHT TO THEM.
A PREGNANT WOMAN WAS TRAPPED
UNDER THE RUBBLE AND WHERE ONLY
EXPECTANT MOTHERS AND THOSE WITH
UNDER 3s HID.
THE KREMLIN WANTS TO BREAK OR
FLATTEN THIS PORT, BUT ITS
DEFENDERS STILL EXACT A COST.
STILL KEEP THEM OUT.
THIS DRONE VIDEO SHOWS THE
MOMENT UKRAINIAN FIGHTERS HIT A
RUSSIAN TANK.
THE SHOTS COME AGAIN AND AGAIN,
REMOVING ONE OF THE TANKS
TRACKS.
THE CREW ARE HIT AS THEY TRY TO
FLEE.
NO ROOM FOR MERCY IN A CITY THAT
HAS LITTLE SPACE LEFT FOR LIFE
ITSELF.
NOW, BECKY HERE IN ODESA,
HEIGHTENED ANXIETY, WE HEARD
SIRENS IN THE MORNING AND WE
ALSO HEARD FROM A LOCAL OFFICIAL
COMMENTING ON VIDEO CIRCULATING
ON SOCIAL MEDIA THAT SEEMED TO
SHOW AS MANY AS FIVE SHIPS ON
THE HORIZON.
THE OFFICIALS SAYING THAT THERE
WAS NO REAL CAUSE FOR CONCERN,
THAT THESE MAY WELL HAVE BEEN
RUSSIAN SHIPS AND THEY ARE
MANEUVERING TO HEIGHTENED
ANXIETY HERE IN UKRAINE'S THIRD
LARGEST CITY.
BUT THAT CERTAINLY IS WORKING,
THERE IS HEIGHTENED ANXIETY HERE
FOR SURE.
WE HEARD LAST NIGHT ANTIAIRCRAFT
GUNFIRE IS A CITY CERTAINLY ON
THE EDGE BECAUSE ALL THE
MILITARY ACTIVITY ALONG THE
BLACK SEA COAST TO THE EAST OF
WHERE I'M STANDING IS ABOUT
PRESSURING HERE AND POTENTIALLY
TH